THE FINDING SHOWS THERE WAS
NO COLLUSION BETWEEN HIS
CAMPAIGN AND THE RUSSIANS.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE
HERRIDGE IS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TONIGHT WITH
DETAILS.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> WELL, THANK YOU, MIKE.
THE NEWS CONFERENCE HERE AT
MAIN JUSTICE WAS CALLED WITH
JUST 45 MINUTES NOTICE.
THE INDICTMENT IS POWERFUL
NEW EVIDENCE OF A RUSSIAN
PLOT BUT DOES NOT NAME ANY
AMERICAN CO-CONSPIRATORS.
>> THE DEFENDANTS ALLEGEDLY
CONDUCTED WHAT THEY CALLED
INFORMATION WARFARE AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES.
>> WITH DIRECT OVERSIGHT OF
THE RUSSIA SPECIAL COUNSEL
PROBE ROD ROSENSTEIN SAID 13
RUSSIAN NATIONALS AND THREE
RUSSIAN ORGANIZATIONS WERE
CHARGED WITH, QUOTE:
CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE
UNITED STATES.
AND ILLEGALLY USING SOCIAL
MEDIA TO DIVIDE AMERICANS
AND DISRUPT A 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
>> RUSSIAN CON SPIRITTERS
WANT TO PROMOTE DISCORD IN
THE UNITED STATES AND
UNDERMINE PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
AND DEMOCRACY.
>> AS EARLY AS 2014.
37-PAGE INDICTMENT ALLEGES
THE RUSSIAN DEFENDANTS,
INCLUDING A BUSINESSMAN WITH
DEEP TIES TO RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
THEIR CO-CONSPIRATORS BEGAN
PLANNING FROM BASE IN
RUSSIA.
THE INDICTMENT SAYS QUOTE BY
EARLY TO MID 2016
DEFENDANTS' OPERATIONS
INCLUDED SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN OF
THEN CANDIDATE DONALD J.
TRUMP AND DISPARAGING
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE DEFENDANTS BOUGHT SERVER
SPACE IN THE U.S. TO CREATE
A VIRTUAL PRIVATE NETWORK
HIDE RUSSIAN ROOTS.
USED STOLEN OR FICTITIOUS
AMERICAN IDENTITIES.
FRAUDULENT BANK ACCOUNTS AND
FALSE IDENTIFICATION
DOCUMENTS.
THE DEFENDANTS POSED AS
POLITICALLY AND SOCIALLY
ACTIVE AMERICANS ADVOCATING
FOR AND AGAINST PARTICULAR
CANDIDATES.
>> Katherine: INDICTMENT
ALLEGES CONTACT WITH MEMBERS
SUPPORTERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THEY WERE UNNAMED IN THE
CHARGE SHEET.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WAS ASKED IF CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS WERE DUPED.
>> THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN
THIS INDICTMENT THAT ANY
AMERICAN WAS A KNOWING
PARTICIPANT IN THIS ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN
THE INDICTMENT THAT THE
CHARGED CONDUCT ALTERED THE
OUTCOME OF THE 2016
ELECTION.
>> THE RUSSIAN OPERATIVES
ALLEGEDLY SOUGHT TO HURT THE
CANDIDACY OF TRUMP'S
CHALLENGERS INCLUDING TED
CRUZ AND MARCO RUBIO AND THE
ALLEGEDLY AIMED TO BOLSTER
HILLARY CLINTON'S CHALLENGER
BERNIE SANDERS.
AFTER THE ELECTION, SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATORS FOUND
RUSSIAN OPERATIVES PLAYED
BOTH SIDES.
>> FOR EXAMPLE, THE
DEFENDANT'S ORGANIZED ONE
RALLY TO SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT AND ANOTHER
RALLY OPPOSE HIM.
BOTH IN NEW YORK ON THE SAME
DAY.
>> ASKED BY FOX NEWS WHETHER
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT WOULD
COOPERATE IN ANY FUTURE
PROSECUTION.
>> HAVE YOU HAD ANY ASSURE
ARNSES FROM THE RUSSIANS
THAT THEY WILL PROVIDE THESE
INDIVIDUALS FOR PROSECUTION?
>> THERE HAS BEEN NO
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
RUSSIANS ABOUT THIS.
WE WILL FOLLOW THE ORDINARY
PROCESS OF SEEKING
COOPERATION AND EXTRADITION.
>> ALSO TODAY A CALIFORNIA
MAN PLED GUILTY TO SELLING
BANK ACCOUNT NUMBERS TO
NATIONALS OUTSIDE OF THE